thank you all for coming today it's it
really is truly an honor to have dr.
Vivek Murthy our nation's 19th Surgeon
General with us on behalf of the newly
renamed department of radiology and
biomedical imaging and on behalf of the
medical student council I welcome you to
the annual Bora Foreman lectureship in
health policy I want to thank our
chairman dr. Jeff geschwind and Sonny
Chung president and medical student
council for their help in supporting and
organizing this event there are over 80
people at Yale and another six
individuals in the surgeon general's
office who have directly helped make dr.
Murthy's visit over these last two days
a reality I cannot mention all of them
by name but i do want to extend
particular appreciation to judy gardulla
wherever she is seated right now he's
worked with me for the last 19 years and
to lieutenant Lauren Etta who is
accompanying the Surgeon General on this
trip and I really think he both
sincerely we are in a really privileged
position at the Yale School of Medicine
selecting our incoming class each year
from among thousands of applicants many
of whom are destined to make significant
contributions in their careers as
physicians physician scientists and
leaders in public health and health
policy in this country and around the
world having been fortunate enough to
serve in the admissions committee for
the past 15 years I've seen our
remarkable applicants firsthand and as a
member of the faculty have seen our
students grow and develop as they move
toward their ultimate career goals they
want to make a difference in their work
as physicians a difference in the health
of their patients in the health of the
entire communities and the development
of new clinical procedures medical
technology and in health care leadership
roles at every level dr. Murthy arrived
at yell in 1998 having already
co-founded to startup organizations that
support under-resourced populations
helping women become educators and
healthcare providers in India as well as
advancing society's understanding of
hiv/aids in the United States and India
at a time when it was far less
understood as it is today his medical
education residency and profession
career have been focused on patient
centered care and on a personal level he
is perhaps the best listener and the
least judgmental person I've ever known
dr. Murthy's ascent to the role of
Surgeon General has triggered
substantive discussion of health policy
issues at every level and inspired huge
numbers of medical students physicians
and other caregivers our own students
show increased enthusiasm for their
capacity to effect positive change in
health care delivery disease prevention
and societal well-being I know I speak
for all of us here today in expressing
our appreciation for your visit and you
return to harkness auditorium the site
of your own white coat ceremony
countless class shows including your own
and many other special events please
join me in welcoming our Surgeon General
dr. Vivek Murthy
thank you everyone thank you so much
Howie I can't thank you enough for not
only that introduction but really for
years and years of mentorship for those
of you who are fortunate enough to be
mentored by dr. Howard Foreman you know
that his commitment to students doesn't
doesn't just end when they graduate but
a continues for years thereafter I also
want to thank the medical student
council leaders who helped organize
today's event I want to thank the
leadership of the medical school which
has hosted me and just made this return
to home such a warm warm trip and I
really appreciate that I also wanted to
thank my my wife Alice who's here today
we got married just three weeks ago
and while Alice and I met through our
work doing advocacy and health care we
didn't realize that we in fact had
overlapped for three years right here at
Yale when she when she was an
undergraduate at Moore's college and
when I was just starting in medical
school so I've always been a little slow
so it took me a long time but with that
said it is so nice to be back here at
Yale I spent five years here exploring
new ideas meeting new people only some
of whom by the way held it against me
that I attended a certain school in
Cambridge for college but before I begin
my remarks I I have a confession to make
that was triggered in part by my meeting
with President salivate yesterday you
know when I was an undergraduate as some
of my mentors like dr. BIA knows I would
always look for quiet places to go and
to reflect to read to just think to
write in my journal and after exploring
a number of places here on the medical
campus I started to you know go further
to the undergraduate campus uphill house
Avenue and on Hillas Avenue I found this
beautiful building that had these
sprawling grounds with these beautiful
trees with long droopy branches where I
could just sit underneath those trees
and write and reflect and think and so
that's what I did I would go to that to
that that house and to that yard often I
would sit there i would take naps
sometimes when i was a you know when i
was tired i would bring food and eat
picnics and I even bring friends there
and say you know there's this amazingly
peaceful beautiful place you have to
come there let's just check it out
together and so that's what I did for
years and then I started at the business
school which happened to be right across
the street from this beautiful location
and I told some of my new classmates hey
i know this gem this incredible place
that you have to come to and we'll hang
out there and I remember I took a friend
over there and he stopped as soon as we
got into the to the front of the
building he said this is where you've
been hanging out I said yeah for years
he said this is President Levin's house
so all this to say that if later today
if you happen to walk uphill house
having you and see somebody in the
uniform that looks like this hanging out
on the lawn just please don't tell
anyone don't call it but when I wasn't
loitering at the president's house in
his backyard I was spending really
valuable valuable times with friends and
with faculty here at Yale and the
University came to be much more than
just a place for education it came to be
a home for me and he was here that i
found a thoughtful community of students
and faculty members who not only taught
me about medicine and about life but who
believed in me at times when I doubted
myself when I was uncertain about the
future and it was these people who
helped me build a foundation for the
rest of my life and it is for that
reason that no matter where I go whether
it's through it was to residency
afterward or two jobs in DC or wherever
whatever may come in the future I will
always remain grateful to Yale for all
that it's given me the real power though
in beauty in this place is that each of
us has a different story to tell and
each of you is here for a reason that
reason isn't necessarily where you're
from it's not necessarily necessarily
the job that your parents do even if
they are in medicine but you're all here
because you know that you are capable of
accomplishing something big and you know
in your heart that big changes are
coming to our profession and that you
have a role to play in determining what
this change means for our patients when
I was a student at Yale I had absolutely
no idea that I would be Surgeon General
someday but what I did know is that I
was lucky to be here my father was
supposed to be a farmer in rural India
his father was a farmer who grew
coconuts Cameron and mangoes and rice my
father for years thought that he would
follow in his footsteps but somehow
through a mix of determination and luck
he became a doctor
and he made his he married my mother and
he made his way to the United States
when my family arrived here we didn't
have much in the way of resources or
money we didn't know many people in the
United States but my parents set up a
medical clinic where my father saw
patients where my mother ran the
operation and together over time they
built these extraordinary relationships
with patients the ones that ultimately
inspired me to go into medicine myself
now periodically my family would reflect
on our journey and we would reflect on
how grateful and lucky we were to live
in a country where there are so many
doors of opportunity that were open to
us and we've known though that this
hasn't always been the case the doors of
opportunity haven't always been open to
everyone in America in fact only a few
decades ago somebody like me may not
have been welcome at a place like you
much less in the office of the Surgeon
General and while we know that as a
country we still have a lot of work to
do there are more and more voices in
this country thankfully that are
fighting for equality and opportunity in
medicine and that is a very good thing
but the big reason that I'm here today
is to tell you that we have a unique
opportunity at this point in history to
usher in the next Golden Age of medicine
an age where good health is within the
reach of every person an age where
physicians are moral leaders who
alleviate suffering not only by healing
the sick but also by working to prevent
illness in their clinics and in their
communities our country desperately
needs this but whether or not we create
and maintain this golden age in medicine
will depend on what you the current and
future leaders in medicine do and what
do I mean by that well we know that
medicine cannot stand alone as doctors
and as medical professionals we have a
unique responsibility to not only care
for individuals but to do something that
has been
part of our legacy for millennia and
that's just safeguard the health of our
community as well but over the past few
decades something has changed more and
more doctors have actually become
removed from their communities now I
know it may not always seem so when
you're in the middle of a busy 18-hour
shift or when you're called back to the
hospital a late at night to see a
patient it might feel that you are all
too close to your community in fact but
I'm not talking about that exactly I'm
talking about something larger I'm
talking about understanding who our
patients are beyond their labels and
illnesses I'm talking about
understanding the factors outside the
hospital that influence and determine a
patient's health I'm talking about the
presence of physicians in this social
fabric of our communities in our houses
of worship in our schools and in our
volunteer organizations when you leave
here and finish your training you will
come out being among the best in the
world at treatment but one thing I want
to be clear about is that treatment
isn't enough if we want to celebrate the
Golden Age of Medicine it has to start
with physicians reclaiming their role
not just as health experts but it's
civic leaders who can understand and
address the factors that contribute to
illness in our communities and it's
important that we realize that we cannot
create a prevention based America all on
our own but instead we have to work
hand-in-hand with lawmakers with city
planners with businesses with nonprofits
and with educators to help build
coalitions for health and let me also be
clear that the work of building a
prevention based society doesn't need to
start when you're done with training or
when you finally secured tenure it can
start in fact right now you see our
country was founded on a radical idea
that anyone from any background or
origin could contribute could make a
difference in a meaningful way
and those fundamental values of fairness
of equality and of opportunity have been
at the center of our country's best
moments and fighting over what those
values of mint and who they apply to has
in fact been at the center of our worst
moments as well but today we live in
this unique moment in history a moment
where the combination of technology
knowledge and the breaking down of
barriers have made it possible for more
people than ever before to make a
difference in their community and that
is why I believe that together today we
can create a golden age of Medicine we
can only do this if we have leaders who
are bold only if we have leaders who can
articulate a clear vision for help for
our country in choosing the path of
medicine all of us have chosen to become
those leaders and the current and the
country urgently needs you to be those
leaders I hear about this urgency every
day when i visit communities across the
country is Surgeon General I hear from
mayors and from doctors about how the
prescription opiate epidemic is
destroying small towns and big cities
alike responsible for nearly sixteen
thousand deaths a year in fact I hear
from too many parents that addiction and
mental illness are still seen as moral
failings in our country instead of as
what they are chronic illnesses they
need to be treated with care and
compassion but most concerning to me is
the sense i get from too many people
that they have lost faith in their
ability to improve their own health more
and more people feel that the forces
that determine their health are beyond
their control they feel that their
health is increasingly in the hands of
the food industry of insurance companies
and of others who have money and clout
but there are also reasons to be hopeful
and each of us here today can show
people that they do in fact have the
power to change your health to change
your communities and to change their
country and I draw inspiration from
stories that I hear on the road as well
stories like the one I heard earlier
this week when I was in Las Vegas and
when I met young parents who every day
walk their kids to school 1.7 miles each
way and they do this because they want
their kids to be healthy I also draw
inspiration from programs like the one I
came across in Roanoke Virginia where
the community has come together to teach
children and adults about how to prepare
healthy foods with fruits and vegetables
and they've been able to document that
they are changing the preference that
kids have around food as a result I also
draw inspiration from Indiana where I
visited just a few days ago and where I
found that law enforcement educators and
public health leaders are in fact coming
together to take on the opiate epidemic
which is ravaged Indiana they are
inspiring stories of success like this
that are dotted all across our country
but the challenge before us is that we
have to make sure that these stories are
the norm not the exception that is our
responsibility and I say our
responsibility deliberately because it's
not just your responsibility but it's
mine is as well last week I joined with
a number of nonprofit organizations and
businesses to launch a call to action
around walking and walkable communities
now I know what you might be thinking
walking how boring how could that be
relevant to help but it turns out
walking is in fact quite exciting
because
because it turns out that walking might
be one of the most powerful tools that
we have to roll back the tide of chronic
illness that plagues our country
something as small as walking it turns
out can have a big impact also on
helping us to reclaim a culture of
physical activity in America something
that has disappeared all too often from
our schools and from our workplaces now
everyone in this room may understand
that but think about the people outside
this room at a time when three out of
ten Americans live in communities that
don't have adequate sidewalks at a time
of chronic illnesses like diabetes and
heart disease and cancer are responsible
for seven out of ten deaths and over a
trillion dollars a year in health care
costs we have both an opportunity and a
responsibility to communicate to people
that just an average of 22 minutes a day
of moderate physical activity which you
can get through walking can
significantly reduce your risk of heart
disease and diabetes everywhere I have
traveled talking about this people have
told me that they were surprised and
often shocked to realize it's something
so simple so fundamental something that
we have been doing for millennium could
have such a profound impact on their
health we are used to thinking that
complex problems require complex
solutions but that is not always the
case and what's also extraordinary is a
diversity of partners who have come
together to bring this call to action to
life and to re-establish a culture of
physical activity in America partners
who include not only physicians nurses
and public health professionals but who
also include the National Collegiate
Athletic Association the NCAA the
national council of shopping centers
Johnson & Johnson and a whole host of
other partners who may surprise you but
who all realize that they have a vested
interest in the health of the nation in
our office we're also talking about how
to take on other tough challenges as
well from low vaccination rates to the
prescription Opie
epidemic to nutrition mental health and
emotional well-being and this is because
my goal is Surgeon General is to help
build a culture of prevention in America
a culture that has active living good
nutrition and emotional well-being at
its heart a culture where we also
redefine what success means now we're
used to seeing success and thinking
about it as a life saved with treatment
a research study done or an article
published in a top-tier journal these
are important don't get me wrong but we
must widen our definition of success to
include being a leader in your community
who brings groups together to play their
part in building a culture of prevention
and is a medical community we also need
to start valuing that kind of community
work as much as we value traditional
metrics like publishing because ultimate
success isn't just about treatment it
means ensuring that our patients never
have to walk through the door of our
office or a hospital in the first place
I want us to be a nation that is as good
at preventing disease as we are at
treating it that is the kind of success
that we are after in the end we face big
challenges as a country that's
undeniable we hear about these
challenges every day when we read the
newspaper or watch the news but never
ever believe that these challenges are
bigger than our collective will because
they are not and if you ever doubt this
remember that it was collective will
that allowed a small band of colonists
to take on the mighty British Empire and
win it was collective will that allowed
our nation to face down unspeakable
violence and racism and passed the
landmark civil rights act and it was
collective will that 30 years ago
allowed us to take on one of the
greatest challenges of our time HIV
this is an epidemic that was surrounded
by stigma by fear and by uncertainty
both in the general public and even in
the medical profession I'm sure many of
you may be familiar with the Ryan White
store Ryan was a young man from Indiana
who struggled with hemophilia and he was
infected with HIV through a blood
transfusion and Ryan face it incredible
prejudice and even hate from those who
were around him and yet when he was
presented with the opportunity to lead
he took that opportunity and he along
with his mother Jeanne made it their
life's work to change hearts and minds
and today thanks to that work thanks to
their leadership over 530,000 Americans
received treatment through the wine
white hiv/aids program and although we
have made great progress in our fight
against HIV we all know that we have a
long way to go last week I was at the
White House celebrating the 25th
anniversary of the Ryan White Care Act
and I was there with Jeannie with her
family and with many of the lawmakers
and staffers who helped make the Ryan
White Care Act a reality and in talking
with Ryan's mother I was reminded that
without their leadership and advocacy we
would not have this law in fact their
leadership and their advocacy produced
the collective will that we needed so
the question that lies before all of us
is what kind of country do we want to
create with our collective will I want
us to create a country where every man
woman and child has a fair shot at good
health I want to see create a country
where the doors of opportunity are open
to all children not just those born in
the right neighborhoods but also those
who come from distant shores and who are
from the forgotten corners of our
country I want us as physicians and as
healthcare leaders to help create a
country where healthy seemed clearly for
what it is the
foundation that makes everything else
possible the most valuable asset we
possess as a country we need to create a
golden age of help to make this happen
we need to reclaim the mantle of
leadership that we had not only as
healers but as protectors of our
community and we need you leaders who
have dedicated your lives to help to
step up and to make this vision a
reality knowing the extraordinary talent
that lies in this room I have faith that
together we can translate this vision
into reality thank you so much for
having me
so we have mic runners on both sides and
in the upper so if you have questions
raise your hand one of them will come to
you at the mic and we will do we have
thank you dr. Murthy one thing that I
heard in your talk was that we should
treat addictions as chronic illnesses
and I was wondering where should we draw
the line between persecuting individuals
for using and abusing prescription drugs
and other illegal drugs and admitting
these types of people into
rehabilitation programs in order for
them to get brother it's a great
question one thing that we people
realize more and more on the ground who
deal with addiction is that we can't
prosecute our way out of the problem
that we have to recognize that addiction
is real that it's not often a moral
failing that it's something that
requires treatment and in fact if we
want to benefit most as a society not
just in terms of help or reduce costs
than we would get people into treatment
or quickly I think the challenge we have
right now is that too many people I
don't see it that way and it's not
necessarily because they're a
mean-spirited or because they don't care
for the well-being of others but it's
because that's how we have been used to
thinking about addiction for a long time
I was on Capitol Hill just a few weeks
ago meeting with one of our members of
Congress and talking about this issue
and he quite openly shared with me that
he years ago used to also look at
addiction as an issue that was a choice
that was a moral failing people had but
he evolved on that issue he evolved
seeing constituent after constituent
visiting families that had dealt with
addiction realizing that it's not just
something that affects a certain type of
person but is something that affects
actually so many of our families whether
you're rich or poor from urban or rural
areas so I think we are we are far scoot
on one
the scale and the way that those
attitudes will change is it people who
have a voice speak up if people who are
affected speak up if people who have
credibility in their communities like
physicians claim that mantle have moral
leadership and speak up about these
issues because what is so interesting to
me particularly about doctors is that we
have so much more power in the community
than we realize people often want to
hear what you think including members of
Congress so the onus often is on us to
speak up to share our views and to do
that through meetings your public
discourse through writing letters to the
editor and offense the more we do that
the more I believe we can change how our
country looks at addiction way in the
back so you mentioned a large number of
deaths from okla opioids but you didn't
mention twice as many deaths from
something else which is gun violence and
I wonder in this era where doctors often
can't ask if there's a gun at home as it
secured safely what the opportunities
for bringing down that number are and I
knows that a politically difficult issue
since the puppet came up in connection
with your own confirmation well thank
you for that question and gun violence
is an important public health issue I've
said that before I've said that since my
confirmation and I'll say it again
because it's the truth and all of us
know it the challenges of gun violence
are complex they're not just about laws
they're also about mental health they're
also about how we fundamentally treat
each other and about the relationships
that we build with each other but one
thing we know for certain is that to
address any of those issues we need to
be able to have a dialogue about the
topic and too often the issue of gun
violence gets politicized one of the
things that doctors can do in a very
powerful way is to help take issues like
gun violence out of a political lens and
to put it back into a human context by
telling the stories of people who are
impacted by
it including patients their families and
their providers this is not just
theoretical I've actually seen doctors
do this I've seen doctors write letters
about the patients they've cared for who
are victims of gun violence I've seen
them come and meet with lawmakers to
share their experiences and their ideas
for what has to change I've seen them
speak at public rallies and move public
opinion and the will of a community
around this issue so this is an area in
particular where I believe the voices of
doctors in communities are needed
because whenever politics seeps in to
our discussions about health care we
need a moral compass in the room we need
a source of a source of credibility of
moral credibility to help bring us back
to what really matters to what the
debate and issues you are really about
which are people's lives and few people
are better equipped to do that than
healthcare providers that's why in the
organization that I worked on before I
was searched in general which is doctors
for Americo you know I worked very hard
to ensure that I did everything I could
to ensure that physicians had the tools
they needed to speak up but that work is
far from done what I'm convinced about
is that we if we were to weave education
about advocacy about how to communicate
with the public and how to share ideas
with your legislators into our medical
training I think that we could create a
whole new generation of physicians who
could be not only leaders in their
hospitals and clinics the leaders in
their communities as well dr. Murphy
welcome back you made us all proud and I
had a question for you with regard to
your call for us as individuals to
engage with our community and build a
culture of trust and health and
prevention we're curious your thoughts
about how we can also focus the efforts
of large institutions such as such as
hospitals or medical schools to better
align their
efforts with the health of the
communities which they serve well thank
you so much for that question dr. gross
dr. Carrie gross was in fact my thesis
advisor when I was here as a medical
student so I had a flashback to sitting
in your office and going over drafts of
my pieces they were all great
experiences he was an incredible advisor
and I was very lucky this is a very
important question because one of the
things that we realize is if we want to
move toward a prevention based society
that we have to do work as individuals
and we also have to move organizations
and some of those organizations are in
the health sector and some of them are
outside the health sector but hospitals
I believe have a powerful role to play
and one of the interesting things that
we are seeing in a post ACA era you know
after the health reform law was passed
is that the incentives around payment
are shifting and the structures are
changing in ways that give health care
systems more of a vested interest and in
some players of cases requirement to be
engaged in assessing understanding and
contributing to the health of their
community that is a very very powerful
powerful set of incentives and tools
because before they were really not that
many incentives other from a moral
imperative for hospitals to really get
involved in improving health in their
community there weren't that many
incentives and ensuring that people were
healthy enough but they didn't have to
come to your place of business in the
first place but I think we have more of
those financial incentives as we see
payment system shifting with that said
not all institutions know how to make
that happen not all of them know where
to get started and this includes not
just hospitals but employers as well I
meet more and more employers when I'm on
the road who tell me that they recognize
that the health of their employees
affects the morale in the workplace and
also falls directly to their bottom line
in terms of health care costs and
productivity loss but despite knowing
that they're not sure where to get
started is one employer asked me he said
should I start by building more
staircases in the building should I
start by putting up signs telling people
not to eat unhealthy food
change the food that I offer in the
cafeteria we're where do I start what
should I do and that's actually where
data ends up being incredibly helpful
because we're employed a lot of times
what employers want to know is both what
would be the highest yield intervention
for me to pursue and then they also want
to know how to go about implementing it
and here too I see an opportunity for us
to work with hospitals and with non
healthcare related organizations to help
them understand what the data tells us
about what kind of interventions in the
workplace and in the community can
actually help us maximally in terms of
prevention some of this data is known
but the truth is some of it is not known
the data and workplace wellness for
example has a long way to go we have
much more research to do there to have a
truly robust understanding of the full
array of things that we can do to ensure
that we are reducing the incidence of
illness but that's again where
researchers can come in and play a role
in helping us identify in pinpoint areas
of study that can help us in very
practical ways figure out where
institutions should direct their efforts
so I really think you know in some that
the institutions need people like you
who understand the importance of
prevention will understand the data
behind it and who can also be connectors
the organizations that actually have the
know-how in implementation and this is a
let me just make this final point
because it's so important in medicine i
feel that part of our culture is that we
often feel that we have to know
everything we have to have all the tools
necessary to get the job done and that's
just not always the case you may not
know for example which wellness programs
are the best for a business to employ
you may not always know what programs or
how yale-new Haven Hospital or sane rate
should go about implementing a community
prevention initiative but as healthcare
providers i think it's increasingly
important that we see ourselves as
convenors that we see ourselves as
people who can bring resources and
experts and others together and connect
them with institutions and individuals
who are in need that shift from being
individual providers of care to also
being leader
who can communicate and who can convene
that's a very important shift for us to
make it is a cultural shift to be very
clear and it's one that I'm hopeful that
we can achieve quickly because truly the
health of our communities depends on it
thank you I was wondering how do you
think we can better negotiate the role
of government in aiding Americans and
becoming agents in their own healthcare
so for example i'm thinking of the you
know the recent controversy of the past
couple years of the soda restrictions in
new york city you know so how can
government play a better role in you
know making Americans agents of their
own health care rather than being
completely prescriptive it's a good
question and one that I reference a bit
in my remarks because one of my great
concerns is that people have lost that
sense of control in their lives they
feel like they don't have the ability to
determine whether they're healthy or not
and to be clear there are forces outside
that are very influential right there
are some people who live in
neighborhoods where grocery stores are
not available there's some folks who
live in areas where buying fresh fruits
and vegetables is just prohibitively
expensive these are real problems but a
focus on those problems alone obscures
the fact that we have choice and we
often have more choice than we think
they use the example you raise of what
New York attempted around soda policies
back during a mayor bloomberg's
administration while many of those
policies that they attempted didn't
actually pass guess what happened to
sort of consumption rates in New York
City by virtue of the campaign's that
they ran to raise awareness about the
issue soda consumption actually dropped
significantly so does just one example
whether it's soda or whether it's
choices that people make around fruits
and vegetables or choices they make
around physical activity we often have
more choice than we think we have and
part of what I believe we have to do as
a country in particular as a profession
is to help shine a light on the choices
that we do have
over and this is not just about giving
people information because information
is part of the job but it's not it
doesn't entirely cause behavior change I
think anybody who's tried to counsel
somebody about lifestyle change you know
after getting an elevated lipoma lipid
panel understands that but that said in
addition to to knowledge we also have to
make it palatable for people to make
changes in their lives we have to make
it culturally attractive for them to do
it people are more interested in often
in doing things where they see an
emotional connection to it people for
example are more likely to make a you
know a change in their life because they
think it will give them the opportunity
to do something they love like spend
time with their grandkids you know run
more marathons if they love with lever
running running marathons travel more if
that's something that they love to do so
we have to also find what did what is it
that people love what did they connect
with because that can often be our
greatest source of motivation that in
combination with knowledge can be very
powerful in terms of engineering
behavior change
you